well you see this here and this is one
of the best things about working in a
nice old chemistry department is that
every now and again people go shuffling
through cupboards which haven't been
opened in years and years and years and
find some Little Treasures so
this is one of those this is uh did your
child in him poison
um and it's uh in this really unusual
presumably I don't know early 20th
century sample vial here so this is uh
we'll talk about this in a little while
when we go upstairs to the teaching lab
but uh uh it's not a lot in there but
that is I would guess about half a gram
and that would be enough to kill quite a
few people so uh this is uh
something to be handled with care don't
go giving Neil any ideas
I don't know the exact ld50 I haven't
looked it up but uh it's uh and to be
fair it's been in there for some time so
uh may have lost some potency but who
knows uh I certainly wouldn't want to
test that so now this is the so-called a
glycone
what does a glycan mean so this oxygen
over here that would have had three more
sugar molecules on it and I simply
didn't have enough carbons in my
molecular model kit to put those on
um those are there to give it solubility
so you can see this backbone here this
6665665
system here that is the backbone which
we call steroids so this belongs to a
club General class of compounds called
steroids and in particular this is a
cardiovascular steroid so this works by
making your heart pump harder but slower
in fact it's the contraction of the
heart muscle that this helps so enables
people with heart attacks so it's still
used for people who've had heart attacks
have heart disease to help their heart
become more strong and enable them to
survive there's a nice story here so
this was uh first found this comes from
Fox gloves
by a doctor called uh William Withers I
believe his name was operating in the
the Birmingham general area back in the
17 late 1700s
and one whose patients came in he had a
real bad heart problem
but sadly the doctor uh he really had
nothing that he could do to help this
guy
it turns out this guy came back a few
months later perfectly okay and what
he'd done is he'd gone to a local healer
sort of traditional folk medicine person
and they've given him a tincture that he
he had taken so the doctor went and
found this lady that had come up with
this this traditional medicine
and although she's very unwilling to
give away Secrets eventually he found
out that fox gloves were part of the uh
the overall mixture that the potion that
she concocted
um so what he did is he went
got loads of fox gloves he dried the
leaves and over the next 10 years he
managed to to get the right dose uh and
administered this and this then became a
a real medicine which could help people
with heart disease and it's still used
today digitoxin is is one of those
medicines today that's based on on this
and you can tell from the name this is a
toxic molecule uh so if you get the dose
wrong and it the dose that you need to
help someone is really small really tiny
0.3 milligrams per day typically
so if you get the dose wrong it will
completely
arrest your heart and and that that is
very likely to be fatal certainly back
in the late 1700s
[Music]
thank you
digitize but if you get the dose right
it gives it that extra pull
it enables it to be a much more
efficient pump it's slower but it's a
much harder pump and you regain that
blood flow it does eventually shrink the
size of the heart I don't know why that
is and the key thing is about this
molecule are two things one is this ring
up here so this is thought to be the
active component quite how it works so I
don't know but I'm sure there are medics
around it that do what is that called
that little so this is a fury known ring
so this is a lactone
this piece here you can see it's like a
like a carboxylic acid but it's now
joined in as part of a ring so that's
the lactone this here is actually an
alkene so you can only
on there's no uh double bonds here but
it is a double box you can see it's just
got one hydrogen of it as opposed to two
that the alkane pieces have and the
other key bit is this hydroxyl down here
and that makes it far longer lasting in
the body
now the two other ones of these come
from the fox gloves one that has another
hydroxyl up here and another one up here
and they're not that useful it turns out
um
so because it's easier to make this or
perhaps it's probably still made from
Fox gloves it's much easier to plant
some Fox gloves and get the leaves than
it is to make this because as you can
see this is a really complicated looking
molecule Professor you said that you
know you told me about the active
ingredient here and the active
ingredient here
couldn't you synthesize something that
has that and that and not have all this
elaborate Shrubbery or is that still
important so that's a good question so
in in the case of morphine you can strip
the molecule down hugely and still
retain that activity
in this case though I I can't say I know
the answer to that my guess is
possibly as long as you're keeping the
orientation of these pieces
and that's fine so the Orient so the
orientation of them and the distance
apart and that sort of could be
dependent on all that
certainly these Rings here and as you
can see it's it's really rigid molecule
it doesn't flop about so these are held
in a certain orientation so this can
spin around but that's about it the rest
of this is completely rigid like a
ladder all the steroids have this type
of structure they have these methyl
groups here
and presumably there's some importance
to that
cholesterol is a one that you may have
heard of that's used in various places
this all these carbons and hydrogens are
really greasy so they get stuck in your
lipid bilayers and
that tends to be where where cholesterol
resides in in your body uh the eight the
the three sugars over here have lots of
hydroxyls and that helps them be what
helps the whole thing become more much
more water-soluble so then it can go
around in your blood go to the right
places go to your heart in particular
and start to do its good action
boiling off so we've got cut some sodium
up we had a
big lump of sodium cut some bits off
that and we're gonna put smaller chunks
in this is going to go in there and
hopefully it will not
be too vigorous reaction there you go so
you can see that blue color